a year ago Venezuelan migrant David
Perez crossed the treachers that he and
jungle between Colombia and Panama
trying to reach the United States but he
fell ill in the forest and was deported
back to Venezuela yet lack of
opportunities at home convinced him to
leave once again I am a little bit
scared of what I've seen on social media
people being robbed but with my faith in
God maybe things can get better Davey is
just one of hundreds of thousands of
migrants from various Latin American
countries and Beyond trying to reach the
United States through this route and the
third by the dangers of the journey
Venezuelans fleeing the political and
economic crisis there make up the
biggest part of this latest wave
followed by Haitians and ecuadorians but
economic woes the covid-19 pandemic and
increasingly extreme weather are pushing
more and more people across the region
to leave their homes
we're seeing many migrants fearing a
hardening of migration policies with the
possibilities of the Republicans in the
U.S so we're seeing an explosion in the
south in Nicaragua Salvador Guatemala
migrants from as far away as western
Africa and Afghanistan have also started
to use this route with much of the
traffic driven by transnational criminal
organizations engaged in human smuggling
migrations become big business for
criminal organizations at times as big
as drug trafficking the clandel Golfo
Mafia in Colombia has total control over
Darian Gap we calculate its 100 million
dollars business there alone
Panama Mexico in the United States have
all announced new measures to curb The
Surge
despite this Davey is preparing to leave
this Monday
what I fear the most is being deported
after suffering so much to get there
that's my biggest fear one shared by
most of those risking it all in the
stretcher's journey but that is not
enough to stop them from trying Bogota
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera